[Musique]
au crépuscule d'un renne de 72 ans le
plus long de l'histoire de france
la succession de louis xiv est remise en
cause par une suite de malheurs qui
frappent la famille royale la minorité
de loups 15 enfants rois à l'âge de 5
ans ouvre le champ des possibles durant
cette époque charnière situé entre les
ors du grand siècle de louis xiv et la
vibrante révolution des lumières le
pouvoir et confier aux régions philippe
2 du d'orléans petit-fils de france et
neveu du roi soleil louis xiv roi
guerrier laisse en royaumes souffrent et
ruiner
entre 1715 et 10 723 le régent temps de
réduire la dette de l'état
il apporte un souffle nouveau et moderne
à la politique et à l'administration du
royaume de france
ce philippe d'orléans était un homme
sérieux qui séparait assez bien les
plaisirs et le travail au service du
royaume
il était aussi un homme intelligent qui
réfléchissait beaucoup qui s'était bien
entouré il va bien gouverné d'ailleurs
parce que jusqu en 1723 on va voir que
c'est quelqu'un qui est plus pacifiste
ça on n'avait pas de mal qu'on avait été
louis xiv il ya très peu de guerre la
crise économique il essaie de la
résoudre en faisant appel ce monsieur
qui avait une imagination de génie
qu'était john law le celui qui a eu le
deal est fabriqué le la première monnaie
papier de l'histoire donc le régent
assure un gouvernement assez confortable
et assez sérieux le régent s'emploie à
nouer de nouvelles alliances pour
contrecarrer les ambitions
expansionnistes de son cousin philippe 5
d'espagne et de son ambitieux ministre
jules alberoni sur les conseils éclairés
de penseurs politiques tels le duc de
saint simon le région cherche
l'apaisement et la concertation à
travers un mode de gouvernance par
conseil appelé police inaudi
l'absolutisme du roi soleil laisse donc
place à une transition libéral la
régence demeure pourtant une période
complexe et méconnu trop souvent noyés
dans les fantasmes des roman libertin
éduqué par sa mère la brillante anne
d'autriche et par son parrain le
cardinal mazarin dans l'idée qu'il doit
s'affirmer comme le plus glorieux roi
d'europe
louis xiv règne d'une main de fer sur le
royaume de france depuis 16 143 il
poursuit l'effort initiée par louis xiii
et son principal ministre
le cardinal de richelieu vers
l'affirmation de l'absolutisme royal
il a la volonté
on pourrait même dire la volonté
forcenée de s'affirmer comme le plus
glorieux roi d'europe et le manifester
dans la pierre dans les divertissements
dans les bals dans les fêtes
bref éblouir
e
louis xiv écrit que c'est sur les
préséances et les rangs que les peuples
mesure leur respect et leur obéissance
pour gouverner sans partage
il s'emploie donc à asservir la noblesse
contraignant les seigneurs à quitter
leur terre pour vivre auprès de lui et à
se soumettre au cérémonial de
l'étiquette qui codifie la journée royal
pendant ce temps des intendant dévoué au
pouvoir administre les provinces
véritable chef-d'oeuvre de politique
l'organisation de la cour permet alors
aux monarques de centraliser le pouvoir
à versailles des seize 182
le chef-d'oeuvre politique de qe
versailles c'est de faire en sorte que
les seigneurs n'ai plus envie d'être
dans leur château est d'être parmi
l'argent et qu'il n'est rien de plus
pressé de plus important pour eux que
d'être vu par le roi ou d'avoir une
petite fonction parfois des fonctions de
deux mysticité de grands seigneurs ont
accepté d'être gentilhomme de la cour
pour avoir l'honneur de tenir le
vêtement du roi pour avoir l'honneur de
lui porter son épée d'assister au
coucher au lever royal à toutes ces
scènes de la vie publique où il fallait
être vu et ça c'est un véritable
chef-d'oeuvre de la politique et on ne
dira jamais assez que la cour a
contribué à l'unité du royaume et par là
à l'unité de ce qui est devenu ensuite
la france
le roi soleil porte les arts et les
sciences
à leur apogée éblouissant toute l'europe
[Musique]
en parallèle il mène une politique
guerrière qui fait de la france un
royaume victorieux mais isolé il passe
trente trois années d'un règne long de
72 ans dans le tumulte des champs de
bataille
le souverain s'appuie sur des hommes de
confiance pendant que nous voir et
organise l'armée française dans le but
d'en faire une invincible machine de
guerre vauban s'emploie à construire des
places fortes stratégique formant une
véritable ceinture de fer pour défendre
les frontières du pré carré royal
[Musique]
colbert se charge quant à lui de
réformer l'administration et d'équilibré
tant bien que mal les finances du
royaume face à l'insatiable appétit
guerriers du roi colbert va mettre en
place une politique que l'on appelle
mercantile qui repose sur l'idée qu'un
royaume est riche si il dispose de
nombreuses espèces n'aurait d'argent et
pour ceux les acquérir
il va falloir avoir une active politique
industrielle et d'exportation
il faut vendre à l'étranger aussi
colbert va développer tout un réseau de
manufacture il va aussi essayer de
développer pour cela une marine bref ses
principaux succès c'est l'économie sauf
que effectivement tout cela va se
heurter à la politique belliqueuse de
louis xiv qui elle va être coûteuse et
va contrecarrer cet effort de
redressement économique
philippe d'orléans le frère cadet de
louis xiv qu'on appelle par convention
monsieur est veuf en 770 princes du sang
appartenant à la maison royale de
bourbon il demeure donc un très beau
parti en 571 il épouse en secondes noces
charlotte elisabeth de ma vie hier la
princesse palatine leroy apprécié le
franc-parler et l'érudition de sa
nouvelle belle soeur de venus
après la reine la femme la plus
importante de la cour le grand théâtre
des courtisans sens est suspendu entre
faveurs et disgrâces et la rigidité de
l'étiquette imposé par louis xiv offre
alors à madame une inépuisable source
d'inspiration
la princesse palatine laissera à la
postérité une abondante correspondance
qui témoignent des moeurs de la cour et
fustige l'hypocrisie des courtisans la
ligne de force de tout son règne et il a
voulu toujours amoindrir le pouvoir des
seigneurs ou fabriquer noblesse un peu
nouvelle qui lui devrait tout et il a
toujours préféré les nobles qu'il crée
lui même et ce pouvoir d'anoblissement
de transformation des bourgeois c'est là
où on a parlé de la fameuse savonnette à
vilain c'est à dire qui permet la
savonnette avinens étaient des fonctions
ou des chats qui permettait de sans
oublir et
louis xiv a toujours en a fait un
véritable instrument de politique en 772
louis xiv se lance dans la guerre de
hollande
il espère ainsi renverser les ententes
et briser la triple alliance conclue en
16 168 entre les provinces unies
l'angleterre et la suède pour freiner
les rêves de conquête de la france
la guerre contre la hollande fait rage
louis xiv s'empare de maastricht en 16
173 vous sont fidèles d'artagnan
trouvent la mort si le roi ne parvient
pas à rétablir l'équilibré économique du
pays
la france demeure un royaume admirer est
l'un des plus peuplés d'europe
l'organisation méticuleuse de louis xiv
qui voit naître l'état moderne constitue
un immense facteur de puissance pour le
royaume et de grandeur pour son monarque
le 2 août 16 174 au château de
saint-cloud
la princesse palatine donne naissance à
un petit fils de france philippe d'abord
titre et duc de chartres
nul ne peut prédire l'incroyable destin
de cet enfant que rien ne prédestine
alors à devenir régions du royaume on
accompagne son éducation par l'étude de
des armes de la diplomatie et de la
culture ancienne
évidemment le grec et le latin le 10
août 778 la signature du traité de
nimègue met un terme à la guerre de
hollande et rapporte à la france la
précieuse franche comté mais les
velléités de conquête de louis xiv ne se
limite pas au continent européen
le pays se dote d'une marine plus
puissante pour contrôler les
exportations développe un empire
colonial et instituts des compagnies
commerciales
la compagnie des indes la compagnie du
levant et des comptoirs tel pondichéry
en 780 2 l'explorateur cavelier de
lasalle revendique pour la france toutes
les terres le long du fleuve mississippi
il leur donne alors le nom de louisiane
en l'honneur de son roi en 783 la reine
marie thérèse moeurs louis xiv ce souci
alors de son salut et observent avec
rigueur les préceptes de la religion
catholique
la même année il épouse secrètement sa
confidente et amie françoise d'aubigné
marquise de maintenant
sous son influence le roi soleil devient
en roi des veaux qui va s'employer à
détruire le jansénisme le protestantisme
pour unifier le royaume dans la foi
catholique
e
à la suite des guerres de religion qui
ont enflammé le royaume entre 15 162 et
15 198 le premier roi bourbon henri iv
grand père de louis xiv signé l'édit de
nantes
cet édit de tolérance instaurait une
coexistence pacifique entre catholiques
et protestants
mais elle a réussi des protestants
devenus des entrepreneurs richissime des
commerçants ou de grands capitaines
suscite bientôt l'hostilité les
catholiques louis xiv initie alors une
grande politique de conversion
religieuse devant les persécutions les
terribles dragonnades un grand nombre de
huguenots s'installe en angleterre
privant la france de ses forces vives
ce qu'on appelle les dragonnades c'est
le logement des gens de guerre et vous
imaginez que loger des gens guerre c'est
mettre à mal les familles leurs biens ça
va provoquer des conversions quand même
en nombre qui vont faire croire aux rois
et qu' il n'y a plus désormais qu'à
abolir s'était dit puisque il n'y aurait
plus ou quasi plus de protestants dans
le royaume c'est une décision clairement
malheureuse en 785 louis xiv porte le
coup de grâce à la cause protestante en
révoquant l'édit de nantes
alors évidemment cette révocation de
10,90 est complètement catastrophique
néfaste parce que les protestants sont
des gens brillants intelligents des
entrepreneurs surtout des entrepreneurs
richissime pour la plupart et qui vont
quitter le pays pour aller travailler
ailleurs
donc que la france va se retrouver
quasiment mise en faillite à cause de
cette révocation
la politique belliciste et provocatrice
de louis xiv alors au sommet de sa
gloire unis bientôt toute l'europe
contre lui en 786 ils affrontent les
puissances européennes coalisés de la
ligue d'augsburg qui souhaite mettre fin
à l'hégémonie de la france finit pétain
un jeune homme intelligent et
travailleur il
il est passionné par la géographie et
s'intéresse paradoxalement parce que
c'est le grand sport de la noblesse
assez peu à la chasse alors qu' il n'a
rien contre l'idée d'embrasser une
carrière militaire
l'héritier de la branche d'orléans et
bientôt en âge de se marier
la famille royale se met donc en quête
d'un parti avantageux alors louis xiv
quand il avait été question que de lui
trouver une femme avait vainement essayé
de trouver une princesse européenne on
était en guerre avec tous les pays
d'europe
plus personne ne voulait donner d'enfant
à la famille royale de france donc il
s'est dit pileux toute manière les
orléans ont toujours voulu un peu trop
de pouvoir eh bien je vais les abaisser
il va épouser mademoiselle de bouaké la
fille bâtarde que j'ai fait à madame de
montespan
bonjour la consanguinité la belle
françoise marie de bourbon est une
bâtarde légitime est certes mais issus
des amours du roi avec sa maîtresse
la sulfureuse madame de montespan cette
stratégie élaborée par le vieux roi ruse
et contribue à abaisser la puissance des
lignes et princières afin de renforcer
l'absolutisme royal
la princesse palatine la maman de
monsieur d'orléans philippe vexé en
question qu'ils épousent une bâtarde
fût-elle légitimer et puis louis 14
reçoit dans son bureau le régent le
futur régent philippe d'orléans en
entretien pendant quelques temps il doit
lui promettre des tas de choses si bien
que le philippe d'orléans sort du bureau
en disant c'est entendu dit il à saint
amand j'épouse mademoiselle de bois
réponse de sa maman ta face une paire de
gifles immédiate devant toute la cour le
futur et jean s'est trouvée giflé par sa
mère et louis xiv était content comme ça
de de garder tous les orléans à sa botte
ulcéré la princesse palatine doit se
résoudre à accepter ce qui reste à ses
yeux une mésalliance qui entachent la
maison d'orléans et dont les normes dote
de deux millions de livres ne suffit pas
à laver l'humiliation
philippe 2 épouse françoise marie de
bourbon le 18 février 16 192
la même année il répond à l'appel des
armes aux côtés du roi le jeune homme se
distingue par ses talents de stratège
lors du siège de namur puis des
batailles de stein kirk et de nervis
donne la guerre de la ligue d'augsbourg
gh s'achève par la signature des traités
de ris vic les 20 et 21 septembre 16 197
qui met un terme à la suprématie
française en europe
en 1701
à la mort de son père fille 2è titre i
duc de relire les naissances se
succèdent et un fils louis voit le jour
en 1703 mais cette union avec la fille
bâtarde de louis xiv n'est guère
heureuse
philippe deux adeptes du courant
libertin délaisse alors son épouse
préférant se laisser aller à la débauche
dans la moiteur des orgies du palais
royal
c'était un personnage assez
extraordinaire que ce philippe d'orléans
capable justement malgré sa réputation
de débaucher que de s'allier avec un
intellectuel comme saint simon saint
simon réfléchissait à la façon de bien
administrer le royaume il avait des
conceptions un peu élitiste mais c'était
un sujet de conversation constant entre
philippe d'orléans et le duc de
saint-simon que de trouver la meilleure
façon de gérer l'héritage de louis xiv
cette amitié entre le duc d'orléans et
le duc de saint-simon nous la
connaissons par essentiellement par les
mémoires les fameux mémoire du duc de
saint simon qui sont constitue un
monument de la littérature qui raconte à
la fois le règne de louis xiv mais aussi
la régence
avant de rendre l'âme le roi charles
deux derniers habsbourg d'espagne
désigne comme successeur philippe
d'anjou le petit fils de louis xiv il
accède au trône d'espagne
clé de voûte de la domination en europe
sous le nom de philippe 5 et va donner
naissance la dynastie des bourbons
d'espagne qui règne encore de nos jours
si le roi soleil avait pu prédire le
destin tragique de ses héritiers
il n'aurait jamais permis
pour contrecarrer les ambitions
françaises
une coalition réunie l'angleterre les
pays-bas lempire et les princes
allemands faisant éclater la guerre de
succession d'espagne des 10 701 cette
guerre permettent à philippe 2 duc
d'orléans de s'illustrer de nouveau sur
le champ de bataille mais elle saigne à
blanc l'économie française cet
absolutisme louis xiv y un an maintien
de finances a marqué durablement sans
doute l'histoire de france et a sans
doute un peu fait dériver la notion
d'état vers la notion d'état vorace et
ça on le doit à louis xiv le roi c'était
lui qui dispensait la richesse il a
prélevé
c'était lui qui la redistribuer et
c'était ça le pouvoir et la notion de
pouvoir et très associé à ça dans
l'histoire de france
[Musique]
on
oh
il
[Musique]
après avoir étouffé les prétentions de
la noblesse créer des intendant dévoué
agents de la centralisation du pouvoir
et façonner une nouvelle aristocratie au
mérite
louis xiv et maintenant le souverain
absolu qu'il a toujours aspiré à devenir
le sommet de sa gloire coïncide pourtant
avec le début du lent déclin de l'ancien
régime
alors que sa succession semblait assuré
le roi soleil voit disparaître un à un
ses héritiers
dans ses mémoires ça simon parle de la
succession des grands malheurs est liée
à la fois la succession d'un roi et puis
la succession des événements on sait que
trois générations ont disparu dans la
postérité de louis xiv louis de france
qui est né en novembre 1661 et qui
mourra en 1711 à 50 ans alors on disait
de lui qu'il allait être fils de roi
qu'il allait être père de roy et jamais
roi et set fut exactement ça puisque
finalement il fut le fils de louis xiv
et de marie thérèse d'autriche
il fut le père de philippe 5 d'espagne
et il ne règne à jamais
à partir de l'année 17 111 une terrible
malédiction semble peser sur la famille
royale en 1711 louis xiv est un vieux
monsieur mais qui règne encore il a
encore quatre ans devant lui et il a un
fils qui peut le remplacer il ya une
cinquantaine d'années
c'est le grand dauphin et oui mais le
grand dauphin meurt en dix-sept sens
donc plus d'espoir de ce côté là dieu
soit loué le grand dauphin avait lui
même un fils surnommé le dauphin qui est
susceptible d'irriter la couronne non il
en est pas question non plus parce qu'on
dit 712 c'est à dire l'année suivante le
dauphin lui-même meurt alors que va-t-il
se passer
eh bien le dauphin avait dieu merci deux
fils oui mais parmi ses fils si on a un
autre qui meurt en 1714
et il n'en reste qu'un tout petit petit
qui a 5 ans en 1715
ce sera notre futur louis 15
la guerre de succession d'espagne est
longue est désastreuse pour la france
si la victoire de 2-1 en 1712 redonne un
peu d'ardeur à l'armée française
l'économie en sort exergue et la vie à
la cour devient morne chaque famille
ayant perdu des proches au combat
la guerre s'achève enfin avec les traité
d'utrecht signé en 1713 louis xiv à deux
autres petits fils philippe 5 devenu roi
d'espagne et qui a renoncé à toute
prétention sur la couronne de france et
charles le duc de berry qui succombe en
1714 des suites d'un accident de chasse
louis xiv sombre alors dans une humeur
noire
le destin du royaume est désormais lié à
la survie de son fragile arrière petit
fils louis le duc d'anjou
ce dernier malade reprend
miraculeusement des forces grâce à la
bienveillance de sa gouvernante madame
de ventadour qui interdit aux médecins
de l'approché préférant le soigner
elle-même
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors on connaît la scène quand louis
xiv et sur son lit d'agonie
il fait venir le seul héritier de la
couronne qui lui reste c'est à dire son
arrière petit fils qui va devenir louis
15 d'une seconde à l'autre et il lui dit
j'ai trop aimé la guerre en cela ne me
mettais jamais
[Musique]
louis xiv c'est un le 1er septembre 1715
c'est dans sa couronne à ce petit roi
âgé de 5 ans mais le 15 est trop jeune
pour régner il s'agit donc de désigner
un régent pour gouverner le royaume
jusqu'à sa majorité
louis xiv transmet à son arrière petit
fils des cartes puissante pour lui
permettre d'assurer sa domination
politique mais le roi soleil a aussi
beaucoup paix mais la guerre et à sa
mort en 1715 le royaume croule sous les
dettes
en effet il met la guerre à tel point
que les caisses de la france aux
archives id le royaume est dans un état
de misère terrible la france est
affaiblie par les guerres incessantes le
poids écrasant des impôts et la fuite à
l'étranger de milliers de huguenots
après la révocation de l'édit de nantes
la stabilité de la monarchie est remise
en question des critiques s'élèvent pour
dénoncer la guerre les inégalités et
pour réclamer une réforme fiscale
louis xiv redoutait l'instauration d'une
régence toujours synonyme
d'affaiblissement de l'autorité royale
l'ordre de succession d'eysines son
neveu philippe 2 duc d'orléans pour
remplir cette fonction de première
importance
mais louis xiv se méfiaient de son
impiété et de sa réputation libertines
ne voyons pas en lui l'âme d'un homme
d'état le roi avait pris soin de le
tenir à l'écart du pouvoir
alors comme son arrière grand père meurt
le petit louis 15 à 5 ans alors
également à 5 ans il naîtra en état de
gouverner mais louis xiv avait demandé à
ce que la régence à bien qu'il ne
l'appréciait pas vraiment fut assurée
par celui qu'on va appeler le régent qui
était le fils de son frère c'est à dire
philippe d'orléans il n'appréciait pas
parce que les moeurs de philippe
d'orléans étaient assez dissolue et il
pensait que son influence sur le petit
louis 15 très néfaste il avait même émis
une réserve en disant que si cette
région ce pouvait être assurée par le
duc du maine et bien il serait le plus
heureux des hommes le plus heureux des
agonisants si je puis dire
leduc du maine étant comme on le sait le
fils aîné qui l'avait fait à madame de
montespan et qu'il avait légitimé le roi
avait donc organisé sa succession pour
limiter les prérogatives de philippe 2
en désignant chacun des membres du
conseil de régence avec lequel ce
dernier va devoir composer de plus
l'éducation et la garde de l'enfant roi
sont confiées à son rival
les ducs du maine première les choses
que va faire le régent c'est d'écarter
le duel du maine de la succession pour
voir gouverner tout seul
le 2 septembre 1715 lors d'une séance au
parlement de paris philippe de flat les
parlementaires il leur fait alors
miroiter le retour du précieux droit de
remontrance strictement limité par louis
xiv
depuis seize 173 afin de maintenir le
parlement dans l'obéissance les
parlementaires comptons d'alors le
testament du défunt roi pour donner au
duc d'orléans les pleins pouvoirs le
conseil de régence se trouve réduit à un
rôle purement consultatif
ce qui est extrêmement importante dans
la politique du régent c'est que il ne s
installe à paris d'ailleurs il s'éloigne
de versailles il rapproche le
gouvernement du peuple et d'autre part
il redonne du pouvoir au parlement
le région instable où 15 au palais des
tuileries déserté depuis près d'un
demi-siècle et réintègre le palais royal
résidence traditionnelle de la famille
d'orléans qui devient le centre du
pouvoir politique est l'antre de la
culture et du plaisir
après l'autoritarisme du règne précédent
la parole et les moeurs se libère et
français ont soif de nouveauté et
placent beaucoup d'espoir en la personne
de louis 15 ce petit roi al'allure
majestueuse laurie jean va gouverner le
royaume
jusqu en 1723 et avec ses hommes de
confiance tels le duc de saint simon
il va entreprendre une politique plus
libérale il est devenu un homme aimable
qui se soucient réellement de son neveu
et prend très au sérieux le destin du
royaume
une fois au pouvoir le régent met en
place une nouvelle pratique de
gouvernement recherchant l'apaisement et
la concertation
il donne à la politique un tournant en
apparence plus libérale en redistribuant
le pouvoir à la noblesse et au parlement
à travers un système appelé police
inédit dans ce nouveau gouvernement
des conseils particuliers prépare les
décisions discuté au conseil de régence
avec la régence apparaît le retour de la
noblesse c'est à dire que notamment des
gens comme ça si mon pouce le régent à
créer des conseils c'est ce qui donnera
lieu ce fameux système de gouvernement
qui était la police indie on retrouve le
mot sinon le conseil et pip poly parce
qu'il ya plusieurs conseils
le régent s'appuie sur le maréchal de
villeroy gouverneur du jeune roi et sur
le duc de saint simon
mais il maintient un conseil d'état a
restreint où siègent ses hommes de
confiance tels son ancien précepteur
l'abbé dubois
les départements ministériels sont
démantelés et les secrétaires d'état
sont remplacés par des conseils
rassemblant des membres de la haute
noblesse
ces conseils particuliers sont au nombre
de sept et composé de dix membres chacun
leur but est de préparer les décisions
royales qui seront discutés au conseil
de régence il ya sept conseils
différents qui composent la police indie
d'abord le conseil du dedans du royaume
qui est présidé par le duc dantin fils
de madame de montespan la charge de
contrôleur général des finances
disparaît au profit d'un conseil des
finances présidée par le duc de noailles
et neveu de madame de maintenon un
conseil de conscience traite des
affaires morales et religieuses
le conseil des affaires étrangères
échoit au maréchal duxelles fin
négociateur dans la guerre de succession
d'espagne
un conseil de la guerre est tenu par le
maréchal de villars qui est le vainqueur
de denain le conseil de la marine
revient au comte de toulouse et enfin le
conseil du commerce au maréchal de
villeroy
le système de la police inaudi révèle
très vite ses faiblesses les conseils
souffre du manque de secrets et des
rivalités entre les membres des 10 718
le parlement pointe leur manque
d'efficacité en septembre de l'année
suivante
les conseils particuliers sont supprimés
à l'exception de ceux des finances de la
marine et du commerce et les secrétaires
d'état sont rétablis dans leurs
fonctions
c'est le premier échec du tournant
libéral amorcée par le régent
le royaume de france croulent sous les
dettes en 1716 afin d'assainir les
finances le région se laisse séduire par
les théories d'un étrange personnage
[Musique]
lorsque philippe d'orléans hérite le
pouvoir la régence il mesure à quel
point le royaume est dans un état
économiquement pitoyable et il a une
idée phénoménale une grâce à un banquier
un banquier écossais qui s'appelle john
law qui va imaginer le papier-monnaie
avec des actions avec des compagnies la
compagnie des indes la compagnie de
mississipi et bien l'argent va flamber
va rentrer les caisses vont se remplir
ça c'est une chose extrêmement
importante las alors ça s'écrit elle a w
mais on le on le dit bien de cette façon
là ce et c'est en fait la première
monnaie qui arrive en france et c'est
d'ailleurs une technique extraordinaire
on achète du papier
john law que les français prononce la ce
est le fils d'un orfèvre écossais il
amasse une belle fortune à londres en
s'intéressant au fonctionnement de la
toute nouvelle banque d'angleterre au
cours de ses nombreux voyages il étudie
les mécanismes financiers des grands
centres monétaire européen pour bâtir
son système john l'as préconise
l'utilisation de titres en papier
monnaie à la place de l'or et de
l'argent
son système financier s appuie sur une
banque d'état qui émet des billets en
fonction des besoins de l'économie cette
banque travaille avec une compagnie
commerciale qui possède le monopole du
commerce extérieur et qui émet des
actions l'ocré la banque générale banque
de dépôt d'escompté démission qui
devient banque royale en 1718
elle est associée à la compagnie des
indes en 1719 cette dernière reçoit les
bénéfices coloniaux créant un monopole
du fret et du commerce international la
compagnie fonctionne avec des
actionnaires sur une économie de
spéculation et reçoit le privilège de la
fabrication des monnaies puis obtient le
bail des fermes général et la gestion
des recettes des impôts directs en 1720
l'eau est nommé contrôleur général des
finances et poursuit ses efforts pour
réduire la dette de l'état
dans un premier temps ce système là ce
moderniser l'économie
parce qu'ils créent de nouvelles formes
d'investissement et les puissances
concurrentes voit apparaître qu'un
quiétude la naissance d'une nouvelle
place financière en europe à l'image de
londres ou d'amsterdam
malheureusement ça ne va pas durer le
système low vie sur la confiance des
actionnaires dans les futurs bénéfices
des colonies et du commerce et dans les
richesses du royaume qui permettent les
rentrées de l'impôt
un parfum de spéculation embaume la
capitale depuis la rue quincampoix qui
va devenir le centre névralgique du
système à paris c'est rue quincampoix
que la s'installer la banque générale
cette rue devient le centre de la
spéculation qui touche tous les milieux
sociaux d'un grand brassage social ya
des hommes d'affaires des hommes
d'église des bourgeois des aventuriers
des marginaux et même des princes du
sang une spéculation illicite est fait
sur les billets d'état et c'est là que
l'on parle d'agiotage on connaît
l'anecdote du bossu qui prêtait son dos
pour la signature des papiers lass ne
veut pas que la spéculation s'enflamme
mais cette machine est lancée et il est
très difficile de l'arrêter
l'abondance du papier-monnaie favorise
cette spéculation mais la valeur des
actions n'est pas basée sur la réalité
et l'eau se montre incapable de verser
les dividendes les agioteurs de la rue
quincampoix paris sur l'inflation
faisons flambée des actions de la banque
peu à peu la monnaie perd de sa valeur
la stand interdit aux français de
conserver plus de 500 livres en monnaie
métallique sous peine de poursuites
il ya une sorte de climat de suspicion
et d'insécurité qui s'installe deux
princes du sang conti et bourbon sont
accusés d'avoir retiré des mains
lyon en or à la banque les affaires
criminelles se succèdent
on retient la sphère du célèbre du comte
de horn qui assassine un agioteurs pour
lui prendre son argent et qui est
ensuite condamné à être roué vif
là c'est fermer la rue quincampoix mais
spéculateurs se retrouvent dans les
jardins de l'hôtel de soissons
s'ensuivent des enrôlements forcés pour
la louisiane qui tétanise l'opinion tout
un blesse va faire confiance toute la
france va faire confiance à l'as
jusqu'au jour où effectivement certains
demandent à être remboursés
et c'est la banqueroute le système
s'effondre provoquant une gigantesque
faillites bancaires et la fuite de l'eau
en décembre 10 720 il meurt à venise
dans la misère
neuf ans plus tard après cette
expérience malheureuse
les détenteurs d'actions sont ruinés
alors que ceux qui ont réussi à vendre
dans la panique se sont enrichis l'état
néanmoins liquider une partie de sa
dette et de systèmes löw a donné un
véritable coup de fouet à l'économie
mais la france se méfiera pour longtemps
des billets de banque
la fin du règne de louis xiv est teinté
d'austérité le souverain est influencé
par la pieuse madame de maintenon et
accablé par la mort de ses héritiers
pourtant le roi soleil a aimé son
plaisir soulevé l'indignation de
l'église et défrayé la chronique en
enchaînant les conquêtes amoureuses
[Musique]
à
dans les années 1700 la vie à la cour
auprès de ce vieux roi des veaux devient
plus ternes et après sa mort la régence
apporte un souffle nouveau qui célèbre
les plaisirs de la vie à travers les
fêtes galantes la liberté de parole et
de moeurs
situé entre le classicisme du grand
siècle et la révolution intellectuelle
des lumières la régence favorise le
développement de la pensée à travers les
célèbres salons et autres cafés
littéraires dans ses lieux de
prédilection se diffusent de nouvelles
idées portées par voltaire ou monter ce
que c'est le début de la grande
évolution des idées il y avait eu
quelques salons littéraires sous louis
xiv on avait eu lui celui ninon de
lenclos par exemple ces salles ont été
ensuite développé madame du deffand
julie de lespinasse et la france est en
train de s'instruire également c'est à
dire que on a mis en place en france un
système de 2 pour apprendre aux français
à lire et à écrire on a beaucoup moins
d'analphabètes sous louis 15 qu'on en a
sous louis xiv en pourcentage et ce qui
est intéressant c'est que alors à partir
du moment où on sait lire on sait écrire
on sait aussi penser et tout cela va se
mettre en place au fur et à mesure du
règne de louis 15 et lorsqu'on arrive au
tout début du règne de louis saez même
marie-antoinette jeunes et bien va jouer
au marché
si la régence porte en elle les germes
d'une nouvelle société
elle reste cependant l'héritière des
connaissances scientifiques brumeuse et
des savoirs du siècle précédent
les médecins font encore leurs pratiques
sur des théories remontant à l'antiquité
c'est le d'hippocrate et de galien et
sont semblables à ceux décrits et
dénoncé par molière
reine de la volupté où s'exprime une
sexualité débridée la régence marque
l'histoire d'un parfum de débauche et de
scandales elle imprime l'image d'une
aristocratie libertines corrompus dans
la moiteur des petites maisons de
plaisir où les corps s'entremêlent le
régent n'a que faire de l'étiquette
imposées par son prédécesseur le duc de
saint-simon la princesse palatine
décrivent dans leur ouvrage un
relâchement des moeurs à la cour
reprochant à la jeunesse sont inquiétés
ou son manque de scrupule le libertinage
c'est d'abord un courant de pensée ce
courant se dresse contre les croyances
de la société les dogmes scientifique et
moraux de l'église celui qu'on appelle
un libertin est avant tout un libre
penseur
il s'appuie sur la raison pour remettre
en question l'existence de dieu et la
morale chrétienne
peu à peu le libertinage devient un mode
de vie dans lequel la recherche du
plaisir est synonyme d'indépendance
moral
tendez plaisir la régence nourri bien
des fantasmes autour de ces libertins
qu'on appelle les roues et car ils sont
jugés dignes du supplice de la roue
alors le région n'a pas que des qualités
évidemment le régent est un est un
fieffé libertin le régent est un
débauché on le sait il a des amis et des
ministres avec lesquels il fait des
soirées crapuleuses à n'en plus finir ce
qu'on appelait les soupers du régent ou
les femmes arrivent et se donne est
mieux manger nu sur les tables alors
évidemment c'est pas un exemple idéal a
donné un un petit bambin de 7 ou 8 ans
qui était louis 15 qui prendra goût lui
par la suite comme on le sait à ces
soirées de débauche des rumeurs
licencieuse circulant à l'encontre de la
figure et jean marie louise elisabeth
d'orléans accusé d'entretenir des
relations incestueuses avec son père il
serait faux d'imaginer la régence comme
le temps où le peuple pensait tout
entier se laisse aller à la débauche
méprisant toute morale chrétienne
il s'agit finalement des actes isolés
d'un petit nombre d'aristocrates
concupiscent dont les adversaires du
régent se servent pour critiquer sa
gouvernance en réalité la population
française demeure très croyante
cette image de la régence érigé en
temple de tous les plaisirs a été
largement diffusée et exploité par le
genre du roman libertin ce mode de vie
influencent une vaste littérature dite
scandaleuse autorisés ou clandestine et
imaginé par les auteurs les plus
brillants du siècle érotique et
anticléricaux politiques et
philosophiques les roman libertin met en
scène les grands personnages du temps
tel le régent sa fille
l'abbé dubois et plus tard louis 15 et
madame de pompadour
diderot publie anonymement en 1748 les
bijoux indiscrets
il raconte alors l'histoire de me rosa
en laquelle on devine madame de
pompadour et du sultan mango ghoul alias
louis 15 lequel possède un anneau
magique capable de faire parler le sexe
des femmes la clau avec les liaisons
dangereuses
puis le marquis de sade avec les 120
journées de sodome où l'école du
libertinage porteront le genre à son
apogée
ses romans suggèrent les rapports
intimes entre sexe politique et pouvoir
les révolutionnaires vont d'ailleurs
s'appuyer sur les aventures amoureuses
et les caprices sexuels des libertins
pour dénoncer le despotisme des grands
dès sa prise de pouvoir en 1715 le
région doit affronter des tensions
religieuses à l'intérieur du royaume et
conclure de nouvelles alliances à
l'extérieur pour assurer la sécurité de
l'europe des courants religieux de
jansénisme le gallicanisme et de riches
et risme se regroupent pour faire front
contre rome il se dresse contre la bulle
unis giny tous fulminé par le pape
clément 11 en 1713 à la demande de louis
xiv
ce dernier entendait contrecarrer les
ambitions des courants anti absolutiste
dans un royaume au bord du schisme
religieux le région multiplie les gestes
d'apaisement en nommant le cardinal de
noailles sympathisants janséniste à la
tête du conseil de conscience des
troubles profonds éclaté engendre une
grande instabilité qui va conduire le
régent imposer la bulle pontificale
il nomme alors au conseil de conscience
l'abbé dubois et le cardinal de fleury
celui ci va devenir un personnage très
important du règne de louis xiv
les deux hommes poursuivent alors une
vaste politique d'affaiblissement du
jansénisme le régent voix très tôt la
nécessité de mener une politique
extérieure secrète qu'il confie à son
ancien précepteur la baie du poids il
envisage de s'éloigner de l'espagne
alliés de la france pour se rapprocher
de l'angleterre
philippe cinq premiers bourbon sur le
trône d'espagne est le petit fils de
louis xiv et le cousin du régent en tant
que prince du sang il demeure un
héritier légitime de la couronne au cas
où le frais le louis 15 viendrait à
disparaître
il a abandonné ses prétentions sur le
trône de france
mais afin de prévenir les éventuels
conflits de succession
l'abbé dubois négocier avec les anglais
le 4 janvier 17 cm la triple alliance
est conclue entre la france les
provinces unis et le royaume de
grande-bretagne de georges premier il
s'agit de lutter contre les ambitions du
premier ministre de philippe 5
jules alberoni qui entend revenir sur le
traité d'utrecht de baden et de racheter
at qui ont mis fin à la guerre de
succession d'espagne
il souhaite en effet restituer à
l'espagne la totalité de ses anciennes
possessions le projet espagnol se
concrétise et la flotte de philippe 5
reprend la sardaigne en deux mois
pendant que l'angleterre organisent la
riposte
le régent hésite il est en bien mauvaise
posture
ils redoutent de devoir mener une guerre
contre son cousin bonbons aux yeux des
français elle apparaîtrait comme une
défense de ses propres droits à la
succession pour contrecarrer les
ambitions guerrière d'albert owni qui
vient de lancer une expédition contre la
sicile le traité de londres est signée
le 2 août 17 ans 18 à l'instigation de
l'abbé dubois
il scelle la quadruple alliance des
royaumes de france et de grande bretagne
avec les provinces unies et le
saint-empire romain germanique
cette alliance garantit les droits
respectifs du duc d'orléans et de
georges premier sur les couronnes de
france et d'angleterre dès le mois
d'août les flottes rivales s'affrontent
en méditerranée sans déclaration de
guerre préalable
mais la mort de charles xii de suède à
l'idée espagnol met un frein au conflit
en 1718 dans un climat où les relations
sont extrêmement tendues en europe un
complot ourdi par l'espagne projet de
renverser le duc d'orléans pour confier
la régence au roi philippe 5 d'espagne
tous les adversaires du régent se
réunissent alors dans ce que l'on va
appeler la conspiration de ces la mare
du nom du prince et ambassadeur espagnol
à paris chargée de l'organiser
l'ambitieuse
duchesse du maine entraîne son époux qui
est un bâtard légitime et louis auguste
de bourbon dans cette conjuration
malhabile et bien vite découverte par
l'abbé dubois à la suite de cette
conspiration
le prince de ces lamarre est expulsé et
les adversaires politiques du régent
sont emprisonnés la guerre contre
l'espagne et déclaré le 9 janvier 10 719
après une brève campagne militaire
philippe 5 congédie alberoni et adhère à
la quadruples alliance renonçant à toute
prétention sur l'italie et les pays bas
la paix est scellé par le traité de
madrid
le 13 juin 10 721 est consolidée par des
alliances matrimoniales la fille du
régent est promise au fils de philippe 5
et l'infante d'espagne doit épouser
louis 15
[Musique]
le régent a travaillé jusqu'au dernier
jour
il était devenu gras obèses important
mais il travaillait il travaille
pratiquement nuitées jour on s'imaginait
pas qu'il avait cette capacité de
travail considérable le région a su à la
fois moderniser l'économie surmonter
cette crise extraordinaire qui a été la
banqueroute de l'ass et il a laissé un
royaume à peu près en bon état à louis
15,1 louis 15 qui n'avait jamais
envisagé de détrôner donc il faut rendre
quelques justice aux régions après
l'absolutisme du roi soleil la régence
apporte un souffle nouveau à la
politique et insuffle une libération des
moeurs
elle permet à la noblesse et aux
parlementaires de retrouver un rôle de
premier plan dans les affaires d'état à
l'aube du siècle des lumières qui prône
la recherche de la connaissance en
s'opposant aux superstitions comme aux
abus de l'église et de l'état
ces derniers ne manqueront pas de tenter
d'accroître leur pouvoir
mais pour l'heure les rouages de la
monarchie subsiste le 15 est couronné à
reims le 25 octobre 10 722 et déclarés
majeurs par le parlement l'année
suivante le régent philippe d'orléans
lui lègue un état fort avant de
s'éteindre le 2 décembre 1723 le roi va
confier les rênes du pouvoir au duc de
bourbon puis à son ancien précepteur le
cardinal de fleury qui ouvre la période
la plus prospère du règne de louis 15 le
bien-aimé